[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous pouvez citer la première dauphine
de l'an dernier et va quoi là et elle
sera elle est très forte elle a révisé
le mistral à ces intrusions pour l été
avec madame de fontenay a été re voir je
devenais alors deux ans c'était le
grande salle et puis il y avait obispo
est géniale idée et obispo était pas là
obispo burkina parce que la salle est
parti en vrille parce que il n'empêche
manqué de bon jean pierre et jean pierre
il fait un bras d'honneur et rentrer
dans les coulisses pendant qu'il y avait
un bruit infernal sans achat
c'est le direct gérard collomb est venu
me voir en me disant vélo maire de lyon
la maire de lille oui ou merde vient
exactement il est venu fois en janvier
vallijee allusif objective à ce prix
c'est vous qui avez un faux nez dans les
coups dit
et moi je suis arrivé j'ai dit je vous
hais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on veut on va perdre le mieux c'est une
belle manière de johnny to fontenay vous
voulez comme moi j'aime bien le petit
l'un il et pas vulgaire pas que miss
france la cecc atteint ses chiennes
[Rires]
ah c'est epub qui peuvent lui encore
montré leur schneck à la télé moi je
suis une vieille dame mais j'en ai
déroulé du câble j'en ai vu passer des
kilomètres de knacki pas végétarienne
mais j'en ai bouffé du concombre
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien utile quand tu veux vous
plaît on va bien sûr qu'il va vous aussi
ah oui et si oui est-ce que geneviève de
fontenay vous manque
si elle me ment oui c'est pas c'est pas
la question d'un compromis seront son
événement d'accord d'accord autant
lembras j'aime bien roland brad va vous
arriver en nombre à cette geneviève donc
on embrasse vous allez pouvoir
l'embrasser en vrai geneviève ce que
nous c'est vrai qu'on aime bien celle
des russes prochaine d'un jeu at il
averti cela nous est cher et moi j'adore
voilà c'est pas après voilà vous c'est
vrai qu'on vous aime aussi
voilà mon on aime aussi geneviève et
jean pierre foucault devait se déguiser
en geneviève de fontenay
jean-pierre de foucauld jean-pierre de
foucauld et utile jean-pierre de
fontenay sans rigoler je viens de voir
si tu as tu l as passé ta tion geneviève
de fontenay jean pierre foucault était
avec nous sur le plateau un peu
d'histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je manque pas la tenir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
oui
vous verrez que je vais les écouter
et quand même limitation de raymond
devos qui dit je te rappelle à mieux
cerner la petite dernière au mans series
pas de problème à me québécois mais
calme toi mais pas faire maintenant je
suis pour la paix dans le monde a dit
manuel et mes toiles à mes toiles
[Applaudissements]